remember that one tweet by joe jorgensen
uh tyler i don't know if you have it or
not
and all of a sudden we get this tweet
about uh what do you call it uh
uh racism and black lives matter and we
need to be
so if you can make that it's not enough
to be passively not racist we must be
actively
anti-racist black lives mate standing in
a solidarity with a morning black
community as we fight together to
unqualify immunity police brutality
sentencing disparities and the war on
drugs not support of any organization by
by that name i don't know how you guys
process it i'm going to speak for myself
you guys can say pat you're full of you
know you have no clue what you're
talking about i see that
and i see somebody caving in to pc
community and you know political
correctness just kind of like hey
beating you down you better give it to
us okay let's throw this out there so
maybe we can get some independent voters
who are uh agreeing with black lives
matter okay let's throw so i can get
some of the democratic voters who come
yeah so that that argument then then all
of a sudden the people that are true
libertarians are like wait a minute
that's not what i believe in i'm out